for a pop-culture icon Jedi Master Yoda
is still a pretty mysterious figure from
his shadowy origins the real meaning
behind his photo moments with Luke
Skywalker this is Yoda story explained
linguists have had some interesting
conversations on the subject of Yoda
speech pattern told the way he does why
his backwards way of communicating has
left researchers baffled and that might
be the way George Lucas likes it the
creator of Star Wars was the touristy
shifty when it came to any information
involving Yoda species and homeworld
there are others of his kind like ya
doll who became Jedi although as yet
unnamed child in the Mandalorian but
Lucas has never so much as whisper the
name of Yoda species
he's even joked that Yoda is the
illegitimate child have come at the Frog
and Miss Piggy but to be really honest
with you I never really figured out
where he came from
what if species is called a no-name
before ya doles creation Lucas
discouraged anyone from making more
beings like Yoda suggesting that he
perhaps wanted Yoda to be the only one
of his kind well that ship has sailed
now the story of a species are still
wrapped in mystery
who knows maybe his species really is
descended from the Muppets in the
non-canonical Star Wars Expanded
Universe now known as legends
we got the closest thing to a true
origin story for Yoda that we're ever
likely to get in legends before Yoda was
a Jedi Master
he had a Jedi Master himself centuries
before the events of the film Yoda and a
human friend crash-landed in a swamp
world there they found Jedi Master in
cars Odell como a member of the high
saurian species Talgo MO told the two
that they were force sensitive and
trained them as as Padawans eventually
Yodo into Coruscant to continue his
training at the jedi temple there Yoda
was trained by hue Aang a mark for
architect droid professor who also made
a canonical appearance in the Clone Wars
TV series once Yoda had his own
lightsaber he was paired with a mentor
some fans have theorized that del Goro
return to Coruscant to complete Yoda
straining but the truth is that the law
gets kind of murky here in ledge
Yodas early time as a Jedi Master was
influenced by a story he learned about
the Jedi Masters K and foo and Chuang
when Chuang died his apprentice
celebrated saying that death is just a
way that people become at different
parts of the force at the age of 100
Yoda became a Jedi Master he was
surprisingly young and spry at the time
if we consider that he only became
geriatric at the ripe old age of 900
those 800 years of the Jedi Master gave
him a lot of time to pass on his
knowledge a role that Yoda became
extremely comfortable with over the
years apparently around 20,000
starry-eyed younglings call Yoda their
master that's a whole lot of Padawans
you knew Master Yoda
yes he taught almost all of the
younglings in the temple at one point or
another having trained so many Jedi Yoda
became a well respected member of the
Jedi Order
at some point in his very long tenure he
was honored with a seat on the Jedi High
Council made up of twelve members the
council ruled over the entirety of the
Jedi Order not all of Yoda's Padawans
became exemplary Jedi Yoda is very last
Padawan was a human man named Dooku
before he became the villain we know in
the prequel films Dooku was Yoda's pupil
as Yoda student
Dooku was impressed for this master but
not entirely sold on the rules of the
Jedi Order Dooku was also something of a
political idealist and after witnessing
the corruption of the Galactic Senate
and struggling with a Jedi Code he
abandoned his rank of Jedi Master and
returned to his home planet home for
Dooku was the planet Serrano but here
acclaimed his rich heritage this is how
he became Count Dooku serving us a head
of state for the Confederacy of
Independent Systems during the Clone
Wars what was kept on the down-low was
that he had a new master Darth Sidious
Dooku had fallen to the dark side during
our first encounter with Yoda and The
Empire Strikes Back he seems like an
eccentric cranky and incredibly wise
creature however in his heyday Yoda was
much more physical than how he solved
problems there was a reason why he was
so revered and it wasn't just because he
was quick to dole out deeper
merchandiser more quotes do not there is
no try
Yoda was very close with a Wookiee race
during his lifetime
having served as an honor negotiator
between the big furry
and their neighbors the Trandoshans he
likely earned the Wookiees trust when he
and his young padawan Duke you came to
the Wookiee home planets of Kashyyyk to
do some pest control at the time the
planet was full of massive rampaging
monsters known as torrent attacks these
venomous creatures craved the blood of
the force-sensitive meaning the torrent
attacks probably must've seen Yoda as a
frog shaped delicacy this and his
negotiation efforts and him the title of
defender of the home tree as any other
Jedi trained as many younglings as any
other Jedi served the order so dutifully
for so long could any other Jedi proved
to be so measured and wise Yoda made
such a name for himself that he was an
obvious choice when it came to
appointing the grand master of the Jedi
Council a title only given to the oldest
and wisest of Jedi Yoda was the Grand
Master when the Buu was invaded which
means he was a head honcho when a small
and slightly sassy Anakin Skywalker was
presented as the possible chosen one
Yoda told him how fear can lead to the
dark side foreshadowing Anakin's
eventual descent as crumb Master Yoda
had a lot of difficult decisions to make
as the Clone Wars fell upon the galaxy
but he was first and foremost a teacher
he assigned a Padawan named ahsoka tano
to Anakin in order to help the Jedi
Knight to get over his fears of losing
loved ones obviously it didn't quite
work out for Anakin himself but the Soka
seems to have done all right from him in
addition to his royal title Dooku served
as a head of state of the Confederacy of
Independent Systems this essentially
made him the leader of the separatist
movement their force against the
Republic and the Jedi Order joined the
Clone Wars Yoda would get to face his
former Padawan head on when he and a
strike team went to rescue obi-wan
Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker who were
defeated and captured by Dooku
despite Count Dooku claiming that the
dark side had allowed him to become more
powerful than any Jedi
Yoda quickly proved that his power was
much greater than his diminutive size
suggested Yoda ha bored him with a cane
but he turned to use Force Lightning
against him with ease when lightsabers
were drawn it was clear that Yoda was
still the master in this fight Dooku
only escaped because he distracted Yoda
by nearly squashing Anakin and obi-wan
allowing the former Padawan the chance
to jump on a ship and fly away from his
old master
toward the end of the Clone Wars Yoda
began to hear voices some council
members wondered if the old Jedi was
going senile
when Yoda appear distracted during a
meeting as it turns out Yoda was just
wondering how qui-gon jinn could have
contacted him from beyond the grave as
he had during an earlier meditation
session this was unheard of and the
other council members were unable to
hear anything or anyone while meditating
this led Yoda to undergo a procedure
that would bring him as close to death
and the force as possible inches away
from dying
Yoda heard chin again who told him to go
to Dagobah on Dagobah Yoda was led to a
cave strong with the dark side where he
saw a vision of a Sith Lord slaughtering
Jedi having seen this horrible future
qui-gon jinn directed Yoda to the
wellspring of life home of the
midi-chlorians there Yoda met with a
false priestess who would help him to
achieve life after death first
Yoda was forced to fight a sharptooth's
shadow version of himself his dark side
motivated by hubris he was only able to
defeat his Wraith when he accepted that
he did have a dark side but that it was
a part that he refused to give in to he
went on to undergo some trippy vision
training in order to learn how to appear
as a for spirit after his eventual death
this ordeal had him fighting evil
opponents on the original homeworld of
the serf and nearly being tricked by the
illusions of some of his dead friends
before the Empire raised her sugg Li
head the Jedi Council wasn't entirely
comfortable with Chancellor Palpatine s
growing power and the galaxy that made
things even more uncomfortable and
Palpatine appointed Anakin Skywalker to
be his representative at the council
thanks to some SIF level manipulations
and creepy visions of Padme Amidala
dying in childbirth this relationship
between Anakin and Palpatine led to the
creation of Darth Vader the Sith Lord
that Yoda had feared would come in the
future as Jedi were being slaughtered in
the Palpatine's order 66 Yoda and
obi-wan conspired to take down Darth
Sidious and Darth Vader who were
actually Palpatine and Anakin at the
Galactic Senate Yoda faced off for the
yellow-eyed Emperor Palpatine and found
his opponent four supercharged with
Force Lightning at first they seemed
evenly matched but eventually Palpatine
gained the upper hand
Yoda knew he was defeated and fled for
his life upon defeat Yoda placed himself
into exile believing that he had failed
before he ran off to Dagobah he
witnessed the birth of
Luke and Leia and the death of Padme
sensing the twins connection to the
force
Yoda helped come up with the plan to
separate and hide the babies Yoda also
planned on training with the four
spirits of qui-gon jinn and he passed
the knowledge qui-gon gave him to
obi-wan Kenobi because of this obi-wan
used his time hiding out on Tatooine to
also learn how to maintain his identity
after death which meant that like Jin
and Yoda he would be able to pass on
wisdom long after he was gone while
obi-wan made himself comfortable on the
sandy desert planet Yoda made the swampy
world of Dagobah his home he made a
modest house there among all the little
creatures of the muck waiting for the
Skywalker twins to grow up and
inevitably cause trouble though he was
physically stuck on the planet Yoda was
still able to keep an eye on surviving
Jedi throughout the galaxy helping them
to avoid the inquisitors that sought to
snuff them out around through decades
after Yoda's two feet at the hands of
Palpatine a grown-up Luke Skywalker came
to Dagobah in search of a great warrior
the Jedi who had taught his own mentor
obi-wan Kenobi
he found Yoda who didn't appear to be
much more than a senile hermit but soon
Luke would find out that Yoda was the
stuff of legend despite his cryptic
speech pattern Yoda proved to be an
excellent teacher as he mentored Luke in
the ways of the force however their
relationship had a substance drawing his
training Luke ignored Yoda's advice and
went to confront Vader when he sensed
his friends were in danger he didn't
return to Dagobah until a year later
when he found he oder ill and dying with
Yoda gone Luke will become the last of
the Jedi so Yoda asked him to pass on
what he knew to others and become a
mentor as Yoda had been for centuries
upon his death
Yoda became one with the force but he
wasn't gone for good because no one's
ever really gone in Star Wars his
training to maintain his identity after
death also helped Yoda appeared one last
time
years later when Luke was at his lowest
drawing his own exile in classic Yoda
fashion he dispensed some necessary
wisdom to one of his students restoring
Luke's faith in the force when he and
the galaxy eated it most check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite Star Wars characters are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]